to brazil now where more than 600 000
people have now died from covert 19.
activists in rio de janeiro displayed
600 white handkerchief handkerchiefs in
tribute to the victims the memorial
ceremony on copacabana beach was
organized by the ngo rio de paz
many in brazil blame president jaya
bolsonaro for the deaths bolsonaro has
consistently downplayed the danger
caused by the virus and anger at his
handling of the pandemic is
growing frustration taken to the streets
of brazilian cities directed mainly at
the country's corona skeptic president
jair bolsonaro
no country has been able to escape covet
19 but many people here are angry that
brazil has lost so many more lives than
most nations
with 600 000 it's the second highest
death rate worldwide and per capita
brazil is among the top 10 countries
suffering the greatest losses
is a pandemic denialist government
spreading a policy of death whose
economic agenda has driven people to
starvation
we are in a desperate situation here and
the president doesn't seem to care
even as brazil dominated global
headlines with spikes and infections and
images of mass graves shared around the
world bolsonaro didn't change his tune
calling the deadly virus just a little
flu
and minimizing the strain and losses
people were suffering from
he has also repeatedly spoken out
against mask wearing and vaccines while
promoting unproven medicines for use by
doctors including recently in a speech
at the united nations
we respect the patient and doctor
relationship with the decision on the
medication to be used and the potential
for off-label use
[Music]
within the government there is also
frustration
for months brazil's senate has been
investigating bolsonaro's pandemic
management including the use of taxpayer
money to purchase experimental medicines
just last week whistleblowers detailed
information about a hospital chain
pushing the use of such off-label meds
on the elderly
so the doctors explained to me they gave
the covet kit of meds to the patients
and told them
i have to give this to you because if i
don't they can fire me
but i can tell you that if you take
anything from here
take only the proteins and the vitamins
because the other medicines besides
having no efficacy could be dangerous
specifically for the elderly
bolsonaro's approval rating has dropped
to just 22 percent
but not everyone has criticism for the
president on september 7th large crowds
came out to show support for bolsonaro
on national day
but as the pandemic continues to take
lives several local governments are
moving forward with their push to
vaccinate
even extending shots now to young people
and more than 200 municipalities are
also introducing a vaccine passport
which bolsonaro strongly opposes
you